- Hi, my name is Lisa Libicki.
I'm a School Programs
Educator here at MoMa.
This is Collective Suicide
by David Alfaro Siqueiros.
So usually when I bring students here
they immediately notice the sort of
top two thirds of the painting
and how sort of crazy
the paint application is.
They notice these applied panels.
Looking at this set of figures
students immediately notice
they're on horseback,
they have weapons, the
coloring suggests a sense
of armor that they're
wearing, and helmets.
We see a second population of figures.
You notice that they have weapons too,
but they're not directly engaging
in battle with this group
rather the weapons have
been turned on themselves
and we start noticing blood
and that they seem to
be committing suicide
as the title also explains.
All these observations
together start building
this very social and
politically minded conversation
about okay, why are they doing this?
And whether or not they've studied
17th century Mexican Spanish history
they can get sort of
like a generalized notion
of like two civilizations in conflict.
So I think this piece really
resonates with students.
One of the reasons I think has to do with
sort of the form of the painting.
I like to introduce the idea
that Siqueiros really felt
that if you're going to be talking
about radical social and political
sort of themes content-wise
then you're method of producing that image
should be equally radical.
Secondly, on sort of
like a different note,
is like hey, this guy was
so politically engaged.
He fought in the Mexican Revolution,
he went over to Spain and
was about to at this moment
when he painted this,
fight in Spain's Civil War.
And yet, in the 1930's did he choose
to paint about any of those things?
No.
Instead he reflected back on
this incident from the 1600's.
And I think students find
that sort of curious,
I find that sort of curious,
and we start to have a discuss
about why would you do that?
What would be the value to kind of reflect
on contemporary ideas and situations
and concerns by reflecting
back on past issues?
And I think that's something that really
almost like challenges them
and really makes their brains
turn in new directions.